- [Conan] You see Chris and Moses, Andy?
- I do, there they are, they're right in front of me,
it's like I can touch 'em!
- [Conan] Yeah, they're on the rooftop right now,
and I think there they are, yes!
(audience cheers)
- Hey!
- [Conan] How are you guys?
Hey Conan.
- [Conan] Incredible.
- I don't know where I'm at, this is beautiful.
- [Conan] Yeah, it's beautiful.
What a sad set we built for them.
(audience laughs)
- Conan do you like our set?
- [Conan] Yeah, it looks yeah.
It's a rejected outhouse from Jurassic Park.
Crazy here, as always, ComiCon is amazingly crowded.
Isn't it amazing, it is so crowded.
(crowd cheers)
Here's how crowded ComiCon is.
I had to wait in line for three hours
just to host this show.
(audience laughs)
I sat there, just waiting.
(audience applause)
- How did it feel, is my question, Luke.
When you declared a boundary with your father.
- [Luke] He cut off my hand.
- I sure would like you to use those
"I feel" statements.
I feel bad, I feel sad, I feel.
- [Luke] I feel like flipping you off right now.
(audience laughs)
Both of you.
- Okay, could have been more effective.
I don't know why you didn't use the good hand,
which would make flipping off much more effective there.
- [Conan] From the stars of Kingsmen, the Gold Circle,
Jeff Bridges, Channing Tatum, Halle Barry!
(audience cheering)
(big band music)
- There's a bank robbery going on right now,
you need to get there right away.
- [Conan] You gave me a little too much.
Let's take it down a little, just say this bank robbery.
- There's a bank robbery going on right now,
you need to get there.
- [Conan] Still not satisfied, but okay.
I'll get them.
(audience laughs)
Oh jeez (grunting).
Okay, hold on.
Hold on, there's nowhere for this foot to go.
Shut the door, shut the door.
(audience laughs)
This doesn't really instill fear, does it?
God, who fits in this?
This is like the Kevin Hart-mobile.
(audience laughs)
(big band music and audience cheering)